aujourd'hui aujourd'hui j'ai envie de
parler de données j'ai envie de parler
de données non mathématique non
statistiques juste de donner je suis un
grand fan de données je suis un grand
fan
et d'ailleurs quand j'en parle à
n'importe qui quand j'expose en fait ce
que je fais la plupart du temps j'arrive
à 10 une petite crainte une petite
ok donc c'est toi qui utilisent m'est
donné c'est toi qui fais n'importe quoi
avec quai oui ce mot mais si je
comprends bien en fait les personnes
dans un monde idéal les personnes
voudraient garder leurs données mais
quand même les exposer je trouve ça à
fait intéressante je trouve ça en fait
vraiment passionnant mais avant même de
se poser la question peut-on arrêter
d'utiliser mes données je préférais me
poser la question peut-on utiliser les
données différemment différemment parce
que je jusqu'aujourd'hui on utilise les
données d'une façon un peu un peu
douteuse on va y venir vous inquiétez
pas avant ça j'aimerais qu'on voit qu
est ce qu une donnée une donnée d'après
moi ma définition c'est très simple il
donné c'est un chiffre ça peut être un
mot ça peut être un fait qui va nous
aider à une conclusion qui va nous aider
qui va nous guider
pas plus pas moins donc si on comprend
rapidement les données en fait elles
sont partout mais le fait que vous me
regarder comme ça c'est une bonne c'est
un fait le fait de manger un repas à une
telle heure c'est une donnée et les
données ont toujours existé elles ont
toujours été à de la préhistoire même si
on leur veut pas en son temps à
maintenant alors qu'est ce qui a changé
pourquoi on a une telle perception de
donner maintenant et il ya dix ans on
n'avait pas cette perception là
les nouvelles technologies les réseaux
sociaux les informatique etc
je pense que c'est l'élément déclencheur
de cette perception plus ou moins
négative des données est cette chose là
est toujours présente elle est présentée
est là elle est venue il n'y a pas très
longtemps
alors maintenant qu'est-ce qu'a apporté
cette chose-là ces choses là
à vrai dire on a porté son appel les 3 v
le premier vpour volume volume la
quantité de données en 2012 on a
augmenté de 400% la quantité de données
on estime qu'il ya autant de données
digitales que des toiles dans le monde
dans mon rôle dans l'univers si un jour
vous décidez de mettre toutes les
données du monde sur cd-rom rappeler des
cd-rom hockey sur cd rom et en faire une
pile on arriverait à avoir la distance
de la terre jusqu'à la lune plus 80
mille kilomètres les volumes le volume
deuxième v v pour variété facebook
commentaires tweet photo vidéo
enregistrement vocal
c'est ça la vérité on a maintenant
énormément de données et de diverses de
diverses formes et on veut toutes les
utiliser le troisième c'est pour la
vélocité la vélocité en gros c'est
quelque chose vous êtes c'est juste pour
représenter à quel point arrivée donné à
quelle rapidité et je vais vous donner
un chiffre
ce chiffre là c'est 48 48
c'est le nombre d'heures de vidéos
que nous mettons sur youtube par minute
et ça veut dire si un jour pour une
quelconque raison quelqu'un décidé de
regarder toutes les vidéos du 24 mai et
passerait à huit ans devant son
ordinateur
je trouve ça très impressionnant donc
volume variété vélocité et ça ça nous
amène un grand mot con et maintenant
qu'est le big data et je voulais
vraiment arriver à ce petit cheminement
pour la suite en fait de mon explication
donc sachant cela arrêtons un peu la
théorie passons à la pratique comment on
utilise nous donner comme on utilise
cette ressource redoutable ressources
parce qu'on va arrêter
il faut savoir trouver la donner fall a
travaillé faut la traiter fall a
manipulé avant de l'utiliser
redoutable tout simplement parce que
c'est juste malade ce qu'on peut faire
avec
vraiment donc je vous propose un petit
jeu ce que j'ai fait c'est qu'en fait
j'ai pris certains textes et j'ai
analysé les mots qui revenaient le plus
dans ces textes-là votre but c'est de
trouver quels sont les auteurs de cet
acte
le tout premier side to day steve jobs
qui zappe
j'espère voir un incroyable martin
luther king le deuxième german british
army je pense qu'il est un peu plus
difficile
waouh incroyable incroyable
churchill exactement le troisième
extrêmement difficile un grand chanteur
canadien en plus donc pourquoi je vous
ai fait faire ça l'idée ici c'est de se
dire avec des mots on peut représenter
non seulement l'idée d'un texte
on peut représenter les dés la vision
que le l'humeur l'intérêt et si des
entreprises des grands acteurs de notre
société faisait la même chose avec vos
données vos textes vos courriels aux
lettres ci faisait ça avec vos données
ne posait même pas la question en
passant c'est exactement ce qu'ils font
c'est exactement ce qu'ils font est ce
que je viens de vous présenter c'est
vraiment quelque chose qu'on voit dans
les télécommunications allait vraiment
firme de télécommunications
qu'est ce qu'on peut dire d'autre sur
les données est ce que vous savez que
enfin je vous savez c'est quoi le lien
entre des couches et une bière
exactement une enseigne en fait à
déterminer que les hommes qui venaient
acheter des couches acheter très
fréquemment de bière avec
alors qu'est ce qu'on fait avec qu'est
ce qu'on veut c'est quoi l'action
apprenant fait à côté on est en business
disant c'est quoi l'accent m le rayon
des couches à côté des rayons du des
bières profite tout de suite on a un
profil vous avez mais celui-là vous
allez particulièrement adoré cela une
enseigne utilisent très bien les données
une grande enseigne que vous connaissez
utilise parfaitement est donné qu'est-ce
qui se passe ils étaient les a donnés
pour vraiment vous donnez des enfin vous
offrir des promotions
ils savent ciblées quels sont vos
besoins dans le futur et un jour un père
arrive énervé en disant faut arrêter vos
bêtises et éviter la prochaine fois
d'envoyer les promotions de produits de
femmes enceintes à ma fille de 16 ans le
manager pour polluer ces rayons du big
data sait rien des données il se fait
incendier
alors il s'excuse et en tant que bons
managers il le rappelle une semaine plus
tard nous armons quand elle le rappelle
le père il est un peu plus silencieux le
pain silencieux et va même avouer qu'en
réalité
sa fille est enceinte
morale de l'histoire ils ont déterminé
que la fille était enceinte et comment
ils ont fait ça en sachant qu'elle avait
acheté une pelle crème en sachant
qu'elle avait acheté une telle sacs et
des suppléments de magnésium dernier
petit exemple politique
si on arrive à déterminer qu'est ce qui
va vous faire dépenser de l'argent
en 2012 on a déterminé que les hommes
étaient prêts à payer beaucoup d'argent
pour voir pour avoir un dîner avec sarah
jessica parker les femmes
george clooney est ce qu'on a fait on a
réuni les deux et on a mis les tables à
40000 dollars
donc vous voyez que il ya un côté
business sur les données il ya un grand
côté business il ya on sait où on essaie
de se lever changé on sait de les
acheter on essaie de d'être le meilleur
là dedans d'ailleurs en 2012 obama le
président obama a investi 200 millions
de dollars dans le big data seulement
dans la recherche et développement
alors vous en pensez
personnellement je trouve ça regrettable
je suis dans une école de business ok
mais j'estime que cette utilisation est
clairement clairement égoïste on
pourrait utiliser données d'une manière
toute autre est révolutionnée on est
vraiment dans un monde où les choses
sont clairement balancer vers le profit
et je trouve sincèrement triste tout les
tous les exemples que je vous ai donné
c'est vraiment un lien avec l'argent le
profit mais si on utilisait les données
pour améliorer les choses si par exemple
nous utilisions les données pour la
santé qu'est ce qu'on ferait dans la
santé on verrait en fait c'est même une
application maintenant les personnes qui
twitte des symptômes donc sur twitter on
pourrait on retrace en fête ou d'où nous
vient l'épidémie la provenance de
l'épidémie pour mieux encadrer cela ça
c'est quelque chose de beau ça c'est ce
que j'estime quelque chose de beau dans
la santé encore dernièrement il ya un
test sanguin qui arrive à prédire
extrêmement bien si une personne va
avoir une tumeur cancéreuse
ça c'est beau mais pour cela on a besoin
de ça on a besoin de vous donner la
réducation délégation d'ailleurs je me
penche beaucoup là dessus et puis ce
quelque chose c'est vraiment un domaine
que j'aime on pourrait cibler tout
simplement sachant combien de personnes
ya par famille combien d'enfants
exactement il ya dans une famille on
pourrait cibler ce nombre se chiffre
pour optimiser l'emplacement d'une école
en afrique
je suis français mais en allemagne bien
évidemment ma mère africaine et faisait
que les écoles sont placés n'importe où
c'est quelque chose que je trouve triste
donc elle construit en ce moment les
écoles et selon les données que j'essaye
d'extraire je lui conseille certains
emplacements ou encore dans l'éducation
j'ai eu la chance de trouver de d'avoir
leur mandat qui me permettait d'avoir
des données scolaire et j'ai réussi à
voir que il y avait des liens d'affaires
entre une personne qui décroche et une
personne qui décroche pas une personne
qui réussit une personne qui réussit pas
l'idée c'est de se dire si j'arrive à
prédire que tu va décrocher je vais te
donner un programme personnalisé et des
idées
des universités font actuellement cette
chose toujours dans l'éducation
quand vous envoyer les lettres de
motivation et tout ça pour savoir qui
doit la lire
on fait exactement ce que je faisais ce
que je vais faire tout à l'heure on
prend les données textuelles et on voit
c'est quoi les mots qui ressort pour
vous à signer quelqu'un donc les données
ici c'est quelque chose qui marche
encore c'est quelque chose qui
révolutionne un peu le monde de
l'éducation
le dernier c'est le transport et le
transport je me pense sincèrement là
dessus c'est quelque chose qui peut
j'aime je pense quelque chose que j'aime
malgré tous ces problèmes
pourquoi dans cette vidéo vous allez
voir le chaos
il n'y a aucune circulation
strictement aucune circulation elle et
je trouve ça incroyable de ces en
afrique c'est en ethiopie puis c'est
quelque chose qui est présent le
problème et c'est c'est drôle mais c'est
un problème c'est vraiment quelque chose
qui est présent le problème c'est qu'il
ya aucune circulation et l'onu
l'oniam m la même cible est le problème
la qualité donné on n'a pas assez de
données
on ne sait pas si une personne qui a eu
un accident et décider ensuite dans
certains pays où vous sais pas c'est
l'accident
et c'est sur lequel je travaille en ce
moment autre chose dans le transport
vous avez maintenant des smartphones etc
etc vous pouvez signaler certains
problèmes directement pour que votre
voisin ou votre wagon et connaissance de
cette donnée mais pour ça on a besoin
que on a besoin faites de vos données ou
bien on peut même optimisé donc le
déplacement d'un poids a au point b
et c'est ça que j'aime c'est ça qui me
passionne en fait dans les données non
le côté business etc à ses côtés on peut
prendre des décisions qui ont un impact
qui ont vraiment un impact à la fin on
part avec des données informations puis
qui ensuite en impact alors
oui c'est quoi une donnée les données
c'est une ressource redoutable mais qui
sont présentement utilisés égoïstement
par les acteurs de notre société
mais est ce que c'est une raison de ne
pas les diffuser
est ce que c'est une raison de garder
pour soi non donnez moi vous donnez
donnez le moi parce que oui il ya un
moyen de les utiliser différemment les
et diffusé de les utiliser différemment
pour rendre les choses un peu meilleurs
gagnent ils sont versés